The.
Hi, Marco. Good morning.
If.
Good morning, how are you?
I'm good. You joined early, I see. That's why I joined in as well. How's your day? How is it going?
Yeah, no problem.
Days going okay, not so, not so bad. What about yours?
It's getting better. One more day and it's weekend. Yeah, always looking forward for the weekend. So this will just be quick. Thank you for joining our weekly service call. Are we expecting Miranda to join?
Yeah, exactly.
If.
Yep, me too.
I don't think she will be joining, because I mean she would, she's just she just covers for me when I'm not around.
Okay, perfect. I'll just share my screen. Give me like 2 minutes to get the document.
How's work lately? Busy?
You're on mute.
Yes, it has been busy. It has been quite busy, but not as crazy as the previous week when we had our quarter, finalizing our quarter, but it's still kind of busy, you know what I mean? It's a lot of things going on. What about you?
Yeah.
Yeah, same thing, just wrapping up all the service calls that I have for most of my clients, as well as the QB, the quarterly review. I just finished it. How was it? Did you, you went to the sites, right? You mentioned you visited all of your sites.
for the review or you just have one office.
Um...
Um, no, so just one office.
One office, okay. How many employees do you have?
Yeah.
51.
51 and you did one on one for 51 people.
But not, not me, not all fifty-one people, yeah, yeah, no.
Ohh.
Okay, just the leads because you're the director, right?
Yeah, just the people that work under me. So it's like I have like, what is it, 5 right now? Actually, I have more because I have people who are going to be moving to a new position, but I already hired the people that they're going to be replacing them. So right now I have.
You.
Okay, good.
Ohh.
the old people plus the new people, but you know, soon enough, in a matter of maybe 5 weeks, you know, two of those people are going to be moving to their new position. So it will put it back to, I think it will put it to set total. That includes Jane.
And.
OK, alright, cool.
So, can you see my screen now?
Yes.
Perfect. All right. So the review that we're going to be talking today would be last week, April 13th to 17th. So it's already our week number six. Yay. So for the agenda items, all of all of this are the same, the check in and up.
Yu.
Days highlights performance analysis and open Q&A.
For a quick check-in, this is for you. How are things at this moment with you and Jane?
Uh, Fencer, okay. Um, um, you know...
She started taking calls independently. Unofficially, I think it was last Friday, but officially, she's now taking calls on her own without anyone shadowing her. I mean, of course, everybody's there to answer questions when she has them, but as of Monday, she's now...
In a sense, running independent.
Yeah, I heard that as well from her. Any news, any feedback you want to share? Is she doing good? Any challenges?
Okay.
No. Yeah, so far she's doing well. No major issues. You know, not to make a big deal out of it or anything. I already talked to her about this. We were supposed, so they were, today was our...
state of the company meetings. So we have two all-hand sessions that we schedule people. She did not attend the meeting that she was scheduled. She just missed it. So I told her that she needs to make sure that she's looking at her schedule and not miss this meetings.
Because I mean, everybody's schedule, everyone in the company doesn't matter whether, you know, I guess you're full-time, part-time, or, you know, you're employed through, you know, ITBD, you know, everybody is part of this meetings is just because that they can hear the state of the company and everything in terms of where we stand.
as a company. So I already talked to her about that. So I don't think we need to make a huge deal out of it. So yeah, so there's that. But that happened today.
Okay, cool. I'll also check that with her. So for in the future, if there's a scheduled SOC or any kind of tab computer meetings she should attend, right?
Right, I mean anything that is on her schedule is meant for her to be part of. Yeah.
And.
At 10, right? Okay, cool. Thank you for bringing that up and we'll see. Are you aware if she's engaged on a call or something that moment?
No, I know that. So when I reached out to her and I asked her, she was on do not disturb. Now, I don't know for how long she was on do not disturb. Maybe she was on do not disturb for like 3 minutes of a call, or maybe she was on do not disturb for two hours. You know what I mean? Because I was not paying attention. I was paying it.
paying attention to the meeting. But I saw that she was not connected, you know, when I start, once I started looking at the roster, who was supposed to be there and who was not, then I noticed that she had not connected. But at the end, at that point, it was, there were only like 10 minutes left on the meeting, so I...
I didn't tell her to connect at that point. I just told her, you know, focus on the phone and and and and work, but yeah, so I don't think it was because she was on the call. I think it was really just, you know, she didn't look at her schedule and completely missed it.
Okay, cool. So I'll have that, I'll add it to my agenda items once we have our one-on-one connect. So moving forward, she would be able to attend all of your meetings, especially the state of the company. We want her there. We want people to see her, right?
I mean, at least know that she's there. She, you know, in a sense, it was an introduction for new employees. She was named on that introduction, you know. Not that anybody was waving or anything like that, but I mean, there was nobody, you know, you name the people and then ultimately that
person was named in there when they were at least being, you know, their name was being mentioned.
Yeah, gotcha. Okay, maybe we can do it next week. I'll make sure that she's there.
Well, it's not every week, so it's every quarter.
Okay. Every quarter. All right. So moving forward. Okay. We'll see. We'll make sure that she'll attend moving forward. Okay. For the highlights, we just have one. So you mentioned she started doing full-time dispatch. So she's currently at her operational solo. So that's
Yeah, once a quarter.
Yeah.
one of the highlights we have last week. Action tracker, we just have one. Approval of Jane's PTO. So I sent the email already. I hope you've seen it.
Rick.
Yes, so I think it was, was, but I thought it was September.
Okay.
Yeah, it's still in September, so you still have a ton of time to think about it. Just putting it out there.
Oh, I thought, I thought, I thought you guys already had a proof that.
Oh no, what we do is to ask for your approval first before we approve it on our end.
Oh, okay. Oh, okay. It's approved.
Yeah, that's the process. You approve it first and then we approve it.
Oh, no worries. It's all covered at that time. No issues.
Yu.
No, I, yeah, I already had checked, you know, I had checked, how's it called, the all the other CSRs, and yeah, I mean, by that, I think it was September 15th to the 18th, at least US.
All set.
And yeah, I mean, there was nobody else on vacation that time. So I thought when you guys had sent that, it was more like of a FYI more than anything else.
Yeah.
But yeah, so I didn't know that you guys were waiting for my approval. So yes, it is approved.
Okay, so that's what we're going to do moving forward. I will mention it over the call and then I will send you the email for receipt and then you'll approve it from there. So we just we have a copy. So it's back and wait.
Okay, so the one thing that I will ask is this. So she's asking for time off, which is fine, the process that we have laid out in here. But when she's going to ask for time off, the best thing that she can do is two parts, right?
do the process that she has to do with ITBD, right? That makes sense. But 2, and maybe more importantly, is that she needs to look at the schedule and she can see everybody that is part of the team. So she can see on those dates that she wants to be off if other people are already off or not.
So if I already have, as an example, two people off, I'm not going to approve vacation because that would leave me to just one person answering phones, if that makes sense, right? So what she needs to do is she needs to look at the schedule. And then let me just share my screen really quick so you can see what I'm talking about in here.
Yes.
Um...
So she looks at the schedule, she sees everybody else who is part of the team, right? And then the next thing that she needs to do, and I did this for her, because I mean, it's not something that we had laid out, is she needs to come over here and what she would do is she will create a schedule entry, and that schedule entry was this, and I just put vacation and I put that she was going to be away from the 915 to the 9.
918.
And then that way that creates this blockers in here on the schedule. So if anybody else is going to try to take time off, they already see that Jane is already off on that on those given days.
Okay, I got that. So she needs to add it to your manage, right? So other people can see it. So it's, so if there's already one people on vacation, might as well not ask for approval, right?
Yeah.
Right.
No, so if she sees one more person on vacation, it's okay. We may have to talk about and figure out how it is. You know, if it's an overlap of one day, it may not be an issue. But if we're overlapping an entire week, that might be something that I have to think about. She just needs
Uh-huh.
Mm.
Maximum 2 people.
Discussed.
She can request it, but if she sees that two people are already off, a third person is never going to be approved.
Unless, you know, there's an emergency, something happened, you know, then at that point we'll try to figure it out.
Okay.
Okay, cool. That I completely understand. So I will cascade that to her as well.
I'm just gonna share my screen again. Let me know if it's visible.
Yep.
Okay. We're here. Okay. For the performance analysis, so we don't have any data yet to, but here I just want to ask, can I have like a data or a recording for her calls?
Is there a way I can listen?
We don't do, we don't, we don't, we don't do call recordings.
Recording understood, okay.
Yeah, it is, you know, at least on the state, it's not allowed unless there's consent to do that, and you know, it's just, you know, we have to get consent also from the client, so we we don't do it, you know, as a practice, we don't record calls.
And.
Okay.
understood. How about a dashboard? Do you have a dashboard where I can check or track if there's any SLA breach within a certain time frame?
Um...
I have to get back to you because I don't know if if the those dashboards shows like a SLA breach. So I have to I have to tell I have to double check what those boards have and then that way I will be able to tell you what we have or not have.
Okay, how do you track their performance? For example, Jane's performance. Do you have like a tracker?
So...
So, the one thing that we do, which are not necessarily those in particular that we have in there, and I think I had shared that with Rick on your team before, so we we we look at calls, yeah, of course, you know.
The 250 calls a day? Ohh, no, monthly.
She's now being judged on that right now. I mean, she's just starting to take calls and she's definitely going to be slower than everybody else. But I look at those, I look at the calls.
And there are certain things that we have as a team, yes, that we do have the SLA compliance, but it's not just her, right? Everybody in the team contributes to that number because it in a sense is for...
P1's response time to triage the ticket is 15 minutes and anything that anything else is then a 30 minute triage time. So tickets should not be sitting on on the board for longer than that. Are there times that it's going to happen? Yeah.
depending on the volume of calls and depending on how many tickets or calls we're getting, but that's kind of where some of the stuff that we're looking at. And I also look, so we use configurations in ConnectWise, which is our documentation, how we document all the clients and all that stuff.
So I look at that ticket that she's triaging, she's attaching configurations and all that. Now I use a third party for some of that. So it's not necessarily something I have a manage. I use for.
A lot of metrics that use a company called.
Cognition 360, which it runs under Power BI, so I don't necessarily know.
how I can share that unless I'm providing that information to you on a weekly basis.
Okay. I guess that's like, it would be a lot for you because it's going to be a manual work if you're going to send it to me weekly. So I'll have to think it over. We can park this. This is just for Jane's scorecard. So just I can score her.
performance monthly. I'll have to check and I'll make sure to collaborate with you if I have other ideas. But for now, I'm thinking to just access her manage and just look at these items very quickly every month. So just I could.
Score her.
What do you think?
Okay.
That works for now, right?
Yeah.
Okay, cool. That's settled then. For operational readiness update, we did try last week all of her tools from her home network and apparently all works are acting up. It's not working.
It's not going to work. We did try to change something from the ISP, but then it's still cracking up. She can't hear the people on the other end and vice versa. What we're going to do in case there's like an emergency or any business continuity plan.
Right.
I'm trying to figure out if she can travel to the office. I'll probably have just to let you know in advance, like 2 hours in advance.
Okay.
Okay, but then the work from home set up for now, we can park that because it's going to be hard. It would take a lot of time if we troubleshoot it more, I guess, two to three days with the ISP.
Yeah.
Okay.
And that's not feasible for us for now, right? Okay, go.
Yeah, yeah, I understand.
Okay. Moving on to the products of the ITBD by Design, that's one, Team GPS and other stuff here, Pro Services, Build IT. So if you're interested in any of them, you know who to reach out to. That's Natalie. Or you can also ping me.
Yeah.
for the details. Okay. What else? Yep, that's the end of my slide. I appreciate you, Marco, for joining this call. I'm going to stop sharing my screen. And yeah, anything else you want to discuss over the call?
Okay.
OK, sounds good.
No, I think we're good right now.
Okay, perfect. So that's all for me. See you next week, Michael. Thank you for your time. Take care. Bye-bye.
All right, thank you. Take care. Bye.